you're a regular at the snl desk
obviously
and we're going to play this new game
called this just in
i love it the whole wall came that okay
we're going to look at some news images
and then take turns coming up with our
best guests at the headline that goes
with the image
this is what we think these stories are
about just based on the pictures
got it good great okay keenan you're up
first
here is your photo what have you got for
us today
this just in uh scottish terriers have
uh
learned how to travel back in time
oh this just in dogs can wear apple
watches
yeah okay and then here is the actual
headline reveal
paradox free time travel is
theoretically possible
researchers say wow that's on npr that's
a legit
news outlet nerds yeah
a hundred percent i get to do a crack at
this all right here we go
all right my turn let's see it oh oh
oh okay uh i'm just gonna riff right now
this just in um if you
care about beauty get ready to have your
face
by a snail i want to spell that out
let's see how can we fill that out um
this just in
escargo not just for dinner
nice okay the actual headline is
snail facials use slime for anti-aging
skincare yep there we go
all right yeah i mean i i use slime a
lot
actually but that was for the kids
choice awards what i'm saying
um okay you're up next keenan go okay
let's see
what do we got oh snap this just in
frogs can lay eggs
this just in uh cadbury announces a
new mascot
um okay what is the real headline here
betty the frog becomes first amphibian
to win the cadbury buddy tryouts
i called it that's unbelievable you i
don't believe it yeah
thank you thank you good job oh keenan i
love you so much it hurts and i'm so
happy for your incredible success on
keenan which airs tuesday nights
at 8 30 p.m on nbc
and it is just phenomenal and be
sure to check out your podcast keenan's
podcast
you already know yes look at you
look at you thank you very much i'm
always getting yelled at for not
promoting it enough so thank you for
that yes it's called you already know
i'm so glad you're in this world keenan
it's a better place
because of you thank you i think i can't
thank you enough and
parental advisory suggested on that
podcast by the way
all right yes i love you beyond words i
i think you're such an inspiration
and you've definitely been a symbol for
how to do it right
in my entire life basically so i'm so
glad that we have such an awesome
friendship
and you're on our our daily television
screens just gracing us with your energy
and love
and we we can't thank you enough for it
you can tell about
your virtual wall those people are
tuning in in their homes
to be a part of your virtual experience
because they love you
but this whole family is it's a
beautiful place like
shout out to all of you and everybody at
home that's watching
we just all love drew from the bottom of
our hearts well we all love
keenan and um thank you vff's thank you
[Music]
keenan